hätte es heute live schön dass ihr dabei
seid ja wir wünschten uns alle wir wären
weiter was corona angeht aber noch immer
hat uns das virus ziemlich im griff die
zahlen sinken nicht etwa nein sie
steigen weiter dramatisch welche fehler
haben wir hat die politik gemacht hat
sie die dinge verschlafen und vor allem
was folgt daraus für jetzt für die
nächsten wochen für die nächsten monate
was muss jetzt getan werden und ist der
gesetzentwurf der ampel partner dafür
auch ausreichend über diese fragen
wollen wir heute diskutieren und zwar
mit einem der profiliertesten
gesundheitspolitiker des landes nämlich
mit spd-experte karl lauterbach aber
bevor wir mit ihm sprechen hören wir
noch mal kurz rein was der präsident des
robert koch-instituts
was lothar wieler heute zu sagen hatte
angesichts der aktuellen coroner lage
insofern sind großveranstaltungen
generell wirklich kritisch zu sehen und
wenn sie durchgeführt werden dann mit
maximaler sicherheit die uns zur zeit
zur verfügung steht also mit all den
werkzeugen die wir haben am besten wäre
es wenn man bestimmte
großveranstaltungen absagen würde ganz
klar
ja einen schönen guten abend herr
lauterbach
also da war schon von
großveranstaltungen die rede da werden
wir auch noch mal ganz gezielt darauf
eingehen können aber ganz allgemein mal
gefragt als ich heute die
pressekonferenz gesehen habe mit den
herren wieder und sparen da kam ich mir
vor wie in so einer zeitschleife
gefangen als wäre es herbst
2020 denn schon wieder war von fünf nach
zwölf die rede das sagt der wähler auch
noch wieder soll bei jeder gelegenheit
am besten jeder seine kontakte
einschränken größere veranstaltungen
sollten auch nach möglichkeit gemieden
werden haben sie da manchmal auch so ein
déjà vu gefühl
ja leider ist das so man muss sagen wir
sind erneut zu spät dran dass es sind
auch immer die gleichen also reflexe
dann wird ein paar wochen vorher
versucht zu erklären dass die pandemie
vorbei sei es gibt ja auch in den medien
entsprechenden also druck dass wir auch
für uns sollen die menschen aus den
reduzierten zu beschneiden es gibt ein
paar lager und dann kommt es zum schluss
doch immer wieder so wie die wahner
feuer gesagt haben wir sind einfach noch
nicht an dem punkt wo die lockerung an
uns lassen können die wir jetzt
zugelassen haben sie haben gerade selber
gesagt wir sind wieder zu spät dran
warum ist das so
ja das bringt jetzt gar nicht so
schuldzuweisungen zu verorten ich habe
ich dann ja die zahl nicht beteiligt ich
habe nie also jetzt in der von mikus
also die akteure kritisiert aber es war
wieder mal passiert also das ist einfach
so fahre ich eigentlich jetzt wurde es
gab also selbst von führenden erste
funktionären gab es den ruf wir können
uns jetzt mehr leisten wir können wie
ein penner oder in england können wir
einen frieden day machen also es muss
hier mal schluss sein also ich sind
durch und die epidemiologen und aber
auch die biologen die wirklich gut im
stoff sind also wir waren einer meinung
das kann so nicht funktionieren das wird
wieder losgehen dem kurs ist einfach
nicht danach was das man also das was
wir jetzt erlebt haben durchhalten kann
manche sprechen von einem versagen der
politik kann man das so sagen muss man
das so sagen
wir sagen ich beteilige mich nicht an
schuldzuweisungen
ich gucke einfach nach vorn das mache
ich jetzt schon seit wochen seit wochen
kennt mich ja dafür dass wir die 2g
regelungen so schnell wie möglich
einführen die wird jetzt noch einmal
helfen also die hätten wir viel früher
zumachen müssen und wir hätten auch die
kontrollen also mit 1 führen müssen
somit einfach nach vorne blicken was
können wir jetzt machen es in 45 sachen
die man machen kann um der situation
noch herr zu werden vier bis fünf sachen
wollen sie die wir gerade noch mal kurz
nennen er hat sich ja gern dass zunächst
einmal die strenge einführung der zweig
regelung also wirklich außerhalb der
beschaffung der grundnahrungsmittel muss
überall zweig eingehalten werden in
allen cafés restaurants bei in allem war
es also überall mal zusammenkommt auch
veranstaltung alles schlecht zweig mit
kontrollen was wäre das erst das zweite
ist muss auch stellen kontrolliert
werden das heißt wenn dies
beispielsweise ein restaurant oder ein
café sich nicht daran er das wirklich
kontrolliert die kontrollen werden nicht
durchgeführt dann muss eben für die
dauer jetzt diese kritischen wochen
musste muss das café oder ist es vor
geschlossen werden bis wir soweit sind
dass wir uns wieder ein bisschen erholt
habe zum dritten wir brauchen am
arbeitsplatz oder 3g regelungen und da
ist aus meiner sicht die
auskunftspflicht notwendig außer
diejenigen die also genesen geimpft oder
getestet sind die können arbeiten
diejenigen denen kann auskunft geben
wollen oder übers ablehnen da ist eben
im moment dann die arbeit nicht möglich
und zum vierten mal so wir müssen in den
schulen dringend wieder die masken
pflicht also anführen und zwar
dahingehend sodass ab werk und schule
aufwärts die maske immer wieder getragen
werden muss das sind die wichtigsten
maßnahmen und zusätzlich die booster
impfung mal gleichzeitiger öffnung der
ins zentrum ich habe immer geklagt
werden wieder zugemacht also was ich
damals schon für falsch fand aber das
wäre jetzt zu teuer die zu öffnen in
wirklichkeit ist aber die nichteröffnung
viel teurer werden die nicht erst noch
kostenlos zahlreiche schwere fälle und
auch zum schluss also an schnitte die
wird vornehmen müssen werden wir nicht
klarkommen ja das sind jetzt also einige
punkte gewesen die wir dann der reihe
nach in dieser sendung auch noch noch
mal besprechen wollen ich will sie
gerade nochmal konfrontieren mit einer
stimme von holger thiel aus gütersloh er
schreibt uns die regierung erlässt fast
täglich änderungen an verordnungen zum
beispiel heute rückkehr zu kostenlosen
tests nachdem die kostenlosen ja
eigentlich erst wieder eingesammelt
wurden und regelungen und die mehrheit
der bürgerinnen hat längst den überblick
verloren das derzeit wo gilt mal ganz
ehrlich und offen gefragt sind sie als
regierung mit der situation überfordert
und handel nur noch kurzfristig aus
panik in anbetracht explodierenden
zahlen wenn sie die situation mal nicht
mit der politischen brille sehen was
macht das mit dem ganz normalen menschen
karl lauterbach
ja das ist alles noch so die regeln sind
jetzt verwirrend auch zum teil
widersprüchlich sie werden nicht
kontrolliert wir haben die kostenlosen
test abgeschafft aber wir haben also die
tests also auch nicht mehr kontrolliert
also ob sie es gemacht worden wären oder
nicht hatte gar kein unterschied gemacht
weil es wurde gar nicht will
kontrolliert wir haben da sehr
unterschiedliche regeln und die wir noch
nicht einmal eingehalten hat schon klar
war dass die fahrzeuge deutlich steigen
zum beispiel in nrw haben wir die masken
pflichten den schulen beseitigt ungefähr
zum gleichen zeitpunkt wurde sie in
berlin wieder eingeführt also das ist
natürlich ein wirrwarr
selbst sich die profis nicht mehr
durchblicken dass es keine frage wir
brauchen halt was so eine klare linie
und diese klare linie ist nur zu atmen
werden man also mit den regeln geht die
also epidemiologisch auch sinn machen
und die regeln die ich eben vorgetragen
habe ich glaube darauf können sich auch
sehr viele wissenschaftler verständigen
ja die bundesweite corona sieben tage in
sind jedenfalls sie klettert den fünften
tag in folge der neue rekordwert heute
263,7 andrea maurer noch mal mit den
entwicklungen des tages und auch den
politischen reaktionen darauf
es gehe jetzt auch um öffentliches
bewusstsein für die dramatik der lage
sagen lothar wieler und jens spahn heute
in berlin wieler hat eine karte
mitgebracht tiefrot dort wo die inzidenz
über 500 liegt die dynamik erklärt er
anhand der infektions lage von gestern
50.000 neue infektionen an einem tag so
viele wie noch nie von diesen 50.000
fällen müssen schätzungsweise
mindestens
350 braucht die intensivstation und nach
einiger zeit werden von diesen 50.000
menschen mindestens 200 versterben jens
spahn warnt vor einem bitteren dezember
und geht als geschäftsführender
ministerpräsident
morgan wird es wieder kostenlose bürger
test geben die vergütung für mediziner
wird erhöht von 20 auf 28 euro pro
corona impfung sparen spricht sich auch
dafür aus den zugang zu öffentlichen
veranstaltungen weiter zu beschränken 3g
reiche nicht mehr deshalb wäre es aus
meiner sicht aus unserer sicht
konsequent wenn wir öffentliche
veranstaltungen erstens nur für geimpfte
und genesene ermöglichen und zweitens
nur dann wenn diese zusätzlich einen
aktuellen test verweisen zweig plus auch
die ampel parteien haben heute über die
lage beraten uneinigkeit deutet sich bei
einer berufsbezogenen impfpflicht an
insofern gehe ich davon aus dass wir
eine einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
brauchen werden um die situation im
griff zu bekommen selbstverständlich
werden wir uns der diskussion stellen es
ist ganz klar aber für uns ist auch
wichtig ob wir das mit milderen mitteln
auch erreichen können einig dass lassen
die möglichen koalitionäre wissen sind
sie sich in einem punkt einen lock down
soll es nicht mehr geben
zum doktor kommen wir gleich herr
lauterbach ich würde gerne noch mal kurz
über die impfpflicht mit ihnen sprechen
also da scheint es ja nicht eine ganz
einheitliche bewerber bewertung zu geben
was die ampel partner an geht in die
richtung fragt uns auch mary shelley 08
lieber professor lauterbach wann kommt
bitte endlich die impfpflicht im
altersheim der jetzige zustand ist doch
unhaltbar können sie sich ihre mutter
jetzt dort vorstellen
naja eigentlich den usa also ich habe
durchaus verständnis für diese forderung
was uns aber ihr weiterbringen würde ist
tatsächlich dass jeder der das
pflegeheim betritt jeden tag getestet zu
werden muss und zwar jeder der dort
arbeitet genauso gut wie also jeder der
dort jemanden besucht die impfpflicht
alleine ist ja nicht das also ist ja
nicht die lösung es sind ja sehr viele
ins pflegeheim ist geimpft und
infizieren sich trotzdem waren wir die
durchbruch infektion haben wir haben ja
sehr früh die also pflegekräfte geimpft
und daher ist bei den pflegekräften zum
zar der impfschutz was infektionen
angeht schon verloren und das
entscheidende ist daher das testen was
man muss jeden tag jeden der an ein
pflegeheim betritt testen das ist das
entscheidend wird also testpflicht
wichtiger als impfpflicht ist für sie
die impfpflicht in keinem bereich
eigentlich sagen wir mal wichtiger als
das testen
also zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist
tatsächlich das testen also für diese
einrichtung wo man andere gefährdet
wichtiger wären diejenigen die jetzt mal
mit wegen im februar oder im märz also
dienst worden sind die können sich also
weil sie im vorjahr ist nicht mehr also
nicht mehr aufhalten kann insbesondere
die astrazeneca dämpfen könnte sich
infizieren und tragen die infektion die
in die pflegeeinrichtung
somit ist das problem wirklich aus so
man muss kästen und zwar diejenigen die
geimpft sind wie diejenigen die nicht
jeder muss getestet werden das kriegen
was nicht also könnte man die debatte
über die impfpflicht eigentlich dann
damit beenden
ja nicht unbedingt beenden wir werden
die debatte natürlich weiterführen aber
die debatte über die endlich jetzt sagen
weil in bestimmten berufen wie kann man
also offen führen was also wäre ich mit
jedem ergebnis anfangs haben was man
sagen ich hab nichts grundsätzlich ist
dagegen
aber ich glaube dass wir also folgen wir
gefahr sehen müssen wenn wir jetzt eine
breite diskussion über die impfpflicht
führen so nach dem motto kommt die
pflicht jetzt für alle dann haben wir
alle eine große politische ideologische
also diskussion aber handeln nicht das
muss jetzt einfach gern dort werden es
muss gar nicht werden testen für jeden
der die pflegeeinrichtung betritt und 2g
überall ausser bei den
grundnahrungsmitteln dass man sich noch
ernähren kann aber sonst alles unter
zwei bedingungen
was halten sie von 2g plus das modell
was herr sparen da die ins spiel
gebracht hat also mit einem zusätzlichen
schnell das noch mal
was hat er ja vorgetragenes für
großveranstaltungen ich persönlich sehe
ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt überhaupt
kein raum für großveranstaltungen wieso
sollten wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wo
die höchsten fallzahlen also in der
gesamten pandemie haben also
großveranstaltungen überhaupt
durchführen also das ist aus meiner
sicht also nicht die zahl
großveranstaltung und zu machen wenn man
jetzt zwei großübernahmen also sage ich
mal zwei geht muss starts zweig dann
habe ich dafür überhaupt nicht genug
test und also das ist überhaupt nicht
durchzuhalten somit war so ist die 2g
nickel ist entscheidend wenn sich alle
impfen ließen und werden über 2 geht
also in allen veranstaltungen wo ich
unterwegs bin bin ich mit einem wert von
unter 1 unterwegs wenn es zwei geht es
also dass videos schafft es nicht an
denn er wird und auch das delta videos
schafft es nicht also unter zwei
bedingungen eine nährwert über alles zu
stellen verstehe und darauf kommt es ja
dann an zumindest mittelfristig also
werden gerade in dem beitrag gehört
einloggen soll es nicht mehr geben
können uns da so sicher sein in den
niederlanden da ist gerade ein teil
locker und verkündet worden vor wenigen
minuten fußball stadien wieder ohne
zuschauer und ähnliches österreich
bereitet ja auch einen locker und
zumindest für ungeimpfte vor was könnte
uns da noch blühen
wir haben jetzt das du zuerst einmal mit
dem gesetz noch slicks und donnerstag
beschließen die möglichkeiten für einen
noch
sehr eingeschränkt beziehungsweise
weggenommen das heißt also ein sonderlob
gab's dann aus rechtlichen gründen schon
nicht erfolgen ich glaube auch dass eine
lok gar nicht die richtige antwort ist
wir müssen einfach die regeln die
funktionieren konsequent umsetzen muss
eben zweig mit strengen kontrollen und
strengere strafen oder sogar das würde
das ganze geschehen beruhigen und würde
tatsächlich die infektionsketten
durchbrechen gleich an lockdown selbst
also den sehe ich im moment nicht unter
ließe sich ja nur für ganz
eingeschränkte bereich so was ich mache
was man sich vorstellen kann ist dass
also die kapazitäten in restaurants
cafés bars und zwar sofort stark
eingeschränkt werden und darüber hinaus
zwei gut macht uns dort auch noch
kontrolliert und bei zuwiderhandlung mit
sagen zu sanktionen dem ganzen begegnet
ich glaube dann bekämen wir sehr viel
mehr also schutz auf die straße ja ich
habe es gerade schon angesprochen in den
niederlanden eben auch die fußball
spiele ohne zuschauer das trifft ja die
leute immer ziemlich ins herz zumindest
diejenigen die sich dafür begeistern
können das würden sie bei uns weiter
laufen lassen oder auch einschränken
vielleicht auch ohne zuschauer in
zukunft spielen also ganz ohne zuschauer
finde ich nicht richtig aber unter nicht
notwendig aber wovon ich habe sehr viel
alt ist das unter zwei bedingungen die
fußballspiele ich habe also besucht
werke wissen sie also auf unter zwei
bedingungen gibt es infektionen aber
sind nicht so viele und in einem
fußballspiel also auch alle im stadion
wenn die abstände da gemacht werden wenn
das fußballstadion nicht komplett voll
ist und man ist zusätzlich mit 2g also
unterwegs sein ist das risiko dass es
dort zu infektionsketten kommt sehr
gering verstehe gut eine frage von anton
j m oder y m herr lauterbach was kann
die politik für uns studierende machen
jetzt das vierte semester fast
vollständig online trotz hoher impfquote
den meisten meiner freunde geht es nicht
gut
aber wir müssen da gemeinsam durch
anders geht es nicht was wir können
jetzt nichts also eher hingehen und
sagen der unterricht findet wieder in
präsenz statt
gerade bei den studierenden ist es
leider so und ich sind altersgruppen das
also viele nicht geimpft sind so somit
also wir müssen noch ein paar wochen
durchhalten zum jetzigen zeitpunkt mit
den rekordzahlen die wir haben und einer
erheblichen gefährdung auf der mittleren
altersgruppe
glaube ich wird es kaum anders gehen als
dass man tatsächlich das präsenz angebot
in den universitäten das gilt ja auch
für meine eigene universität ich bin ja
hier an der universität in köln
weiterhin also also urlaub der professor
und wir können das auch nicht anders
machen wir müssen zum großen teil müssen
wir noch also müssen wir noch über
müssen sie noch online
unsere unser angebot ja also soweit die
die universitäten und die studierenden
gehen wir noch einmal eine altersstufe
runter harry über youtube fragt ist es
noch möglich schulschließungen zu
vermeiden
schulschließungen sind nach dem was wir
jetzt am nächsten donnerstag beschließen
werde nicht mehr möglich also wir nehmen
was wir beenden ja die epidemische lage
und so das führt dazu dass mein
schulschließungen nicht mehr durchführen
kann was sie aber machen können ist
natürlich wir können also masken pflicht
also können wir verhängen und wir können
natürlich auch also die kapazitäten in
den klassenräumen wieder reduzieren wir
können also in thal präsenz übergehen
also hybrid unterricht ist also zu jedem
zeitpunkt möglich und wir können
natürlich auch das testen intensivieren
was aus meiner sicht dringend notwendig
ist
ja sie haben jetzt mehrfach schon das
stichwort genannt ihr gesetzentwurf soll
dann nächsten donnerstag beschlossen
werden die ampel parteien haben ihn
gestern ins parlament eingebracht
einzelheiten zu diesen plänen haben wir
auch noch mal zusammengetragen jetzt
nämlich von laura rosinus und von sarah
tag
landesweiter schulschließung
ausgangssperren kontakt verboten das
alles soll es bald nicht mehr geben geht
es nach dem gesetzesentwurf der ampel
koalition
danach werden aus 18 maßnahmen die den
ländern im moment im kampf gegen korona
zur verfügung stehen sechs wegfallen
sollen insbesondere die regeln das leben
der menschen stark einschränken
dabei gäbe es aus juristischer sicht gar
kein grund den handlungsspielraum der
länder so weit zu begrenzen
die gesetzesänderung ist nicht
erforderlich und könnte auch einfach die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite verlängern und dann einzelne
maßnahmen aus der jetzigen regelung
rausnehmen zum beispiel die nächtlichen
ausgangssperren die wahrscheinlich
unverhältnismäßig sind oder waren aber
das heißt nicht dass man jetzt unbedingt
noch mehr maßnahmen daraus streichen
muss zu dem neuen maßnahmenkatalog
gehören dann unter anderem 2g 3g hrige
masken pflicht abstand und das erfassen
von kontaktdaten
ob das genügen wird um die vierte welle
zu brechen bezweifeln expertinnen
um diese massive welle in den griff zu
bekommen brauchen wir ziemlich sicher
auch kontakt beschränkungen wenn man
schaut wo die infektionen passieren dann
passieren sie eben natürlich auf der
arbeit sie passieren in der schule aber
sie passieren sehr sehr viel auch im
privaten bereich
im privaten bereich hat sie gesagt also
wir gehen das mal der reihe nach durch
kritik kommt an dem inhalt dieses
gesetzes entwurf sowohl was die
zeitpunkt angeht als auch natürlich was
den inhalt angeht fangen wir aber mal
ruhig mit dem zeitpunkt an ist es das
richtige signal jetzt diese epidemische
notlage auslaufen zu lassen wo doch im
prinzip alles darauf hindeutet dass wir
genau das haben nämlich eine notlage
war zeit ist unglücklich dass gar keine
frage und zwar sehr früh angekündigt
worden also von
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen das
also ähnliche lage auslaufen wird so es
war eine gesetzliche korrektur notwendig
werden erhebliche probleme mit unseren
regeln vor gericht somit ist das eine
unglückliche wahl also auch die
begrifflichkeit aber nicht dessen kurz
die regeln selbst die funktionieren und
das ist ja das worauf es ankommt von
daher müssen wir klarmachen dass also
dies also eine seien andere rechtliche
grundlage ist die wir jetzt reden aber
dass die bahn mit also im moment total
zurückgekommen ist und dass wir in einer
notlage sind und dass wir dieser notlage
auch mit aller also mit allem was wir
haben begegnen aber die frage ist ja was
haben sie jetzt noch in der hand also
insgesamt werden die möglichkeiten der
länder das haben wir gerade gesehen die
für die maßnahmen ja dann zuständig sind
eingeschränkt von ursprünglich 18 sind
jetzt noch sechs übrig auf die die
länder dann zugreifen können
ausgangssperren kontakt beschränkungen
zum beispiel die ja teilweise schon in
kraft sind müssten dann wieder
zurückgenommen werden können wir uns das
wirklich leisten
leisten aber nur unter einer bedingung
dass wir die instrumente die wir haben
auch ganz konsequent anwenden wenn wir
das nicht machen wir das schwer werden
wären das also wird es lange dauern und
es werden viele leider muss man sagen
viele menschen sterben das muss man
ehrlicherweise zugeben wir haben ja der
zeitung wer 250 bis 300 tote pro tag das
wird über die nächsten wochen nicht
abreißen kann manchmal ein guter tag
dabei sagen wo unter leute sterben aber
es werde tage geben das sterben fast 500
das heißt wir sind jetzt sehr
schwierigen situation
jeden tag sterben so viele menschen wie
auch so aber sterben würden wenn ein
jumbo-jet abstirbt und das haben wir
schon mal gehabt aber wir sind jetzt
wieder dazu zahlt mal ohne jede not es
wäre völlig und das wäre völlig
vermeidbar gewesen und somit müssen wir
mit den instrumenten die wir haben
besonders drastisch oh umgehen und das
sind die momente die ich eben
vorgetragen habe das wichtigste
instrument ist wirklich zweig überall
und ganz strenge kontrollen sehr
schnelle ahndung wenn man dagegen
verstößt 3g am arbeitsplatz auch
auskunft muss erteilt werden wir keine
auskunft erteilen will alles gute darf
an dem tag nicht arbeiten und eben auch
aus so die situation an den schulen in
den griff bekommen wir müssen die
instrumente die wir haben wie es umso
strenger und konsequenter umsetzen sonst
kommen wir nicht so recht ja es gibt
unheimlich viele zuschriften die uns
fragen nach dem motto warum sind wir so
spät dran und warum hat die politik
nicht früher gehandelt etc das habe ich
sie ja auch schon gefragt ich will jetzt
auch nicht zwingend sich da ständig zu
wiederholen wir haben ihren standpunkt
dazu ja gehört und sie wollen da jetzt
auch nicht nachkarten ist mein 04 fragt
uns über youtube sollten
weihnachtsmärkte trainer
jetzt sind so kurz weg hören sie mich
dann ob das bild ist weg okay also wir
stellen sie uns vor ich frag sie
trotzdem gerne weiter sollten
weihnachtsmärkte komplett nicht
stattfinden herr lauterbach oder auch
nur mit zwei oder drei gewiss da ihre
einschätzung ich konnte akustisch jetzt
nicht verstehen es geht um die wahl ja
es ging um die weihnachtsmärkte ismael
04 fragt uns sollten weihnachtsmärkte
komplett nicht stattfinden herr
lauterbach
ich habe mit den weihnachtsmärkten auch
große probleme also ich würde mich
freuen für jeden weihnachtsmarkt er
nicht stattfindet und wenn man nachts
märkte stattfinden dann sollten sie
tatsächlich also kontrolliert werden dem
sinn davon dass es zwei gebern us märkte
sind und dass also eine begrenzte zahl
von nicht nur auf den weihnachtsmarkt da
ich hab's mir das gleiche auch schon für
karneval gewünscht da ist es aber nicht
umgesetzt worden wir haben dort
unhaltbar zuständig jetzt gesehen wir
werden auch sicherlich also eine
deutliche infektionskette nachziehen
leider somit also ideal wäre
weihnachtsmärkten abzusagen jeder
weihnachtsmarkt er nicht durchgeführt
wird ist ein guter weihnachtsmarkt wenn
man das mal stattfindet dann zweig
einlasskontrollen und ebene reduziert
also
reduziert das publikum also nicht den
üblichen weihnachtsmarkt wo jeder dann
rein kann da wo es sich drängt und wo
man auch gemacht hat laut miteinander
spricht und sich dann mit vielen
infektionen infiziert
das argument wenn wir das gerade nochmal
aufgreifen von frau professor prozess
ist ja dass viele kontakte im privaten
bereich stattfinden und man deshalb auch
mit diesem ganzen g regelungen ob ihr 2
oder 3 nicht wirklich weiter kommt
sondern es brauche dann doch kontakt
beschränkungen das läuft aber dem
zuwider was sie jetzt beschließen wollen
also wasser
war es zu recht auf irgendwas also auch
in den
beratungsräumen sich viele menschen
anstecken das gar keine frage aber
zunächst einmal ist muss ja eine person
geben wie es dann in die in die private
gruppe hinein und damit ist von einer
privaten gruppe zur nächsten also kommt
es eben auch dieser treffen
also im öffentlichen raum wo sich eben
leute begegnen die zu ganz
unterschiedlichen freundeskreisen und
familien hören ich mache es mal ganz
einfach aus wenn eine familie nicht
infiziert und da bist hinweg kann das
jetzt mal nicht weiter wenn aber einer
von dieser familie dann aber einen
anderen infizierten geht es in diesen
familien an dann habe ich zwar immer
sagen wir mal wieder haupt ansteckungen
in den familien aber das bindeglied
zwischen familie und familie b oder mal
wegen gruppe von skd freundeskreis diese
bindeglieder die sind ganz besonders
bedeutsam und diese bindeglieder von
menschen die sich nicht kennen und auch
nicht miteinander verwandt sind das sind
eben diese also ansteckungen stattfinden
also im öffentlichen raum somit also
fotos hat aber es für die unterbindung
der also ketten der infektionsketten
sind tatsächlich die öffentlichen rollen
weil die betriebe die restaurants cafés
die sind da sehr bedeutsamen deswegen
liegen sie da größeres augenmerk darauf
als auf die beschränkungen im privaten
bereich
genau so ist das also die kontakte man
müsse daher wird also wieder zu den
kontakt beschränkungen kommen dass das
nur zwei familien sich kim collins warte
ich hoffe dass zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
auch überhaupt lassen also erstens haben
wir das nie wirklich kontrollieren
können wenn ich an westerwald
kontrolliere was wir leider nicht tun
das ist der skandal ist ja dass wir das
was wir eigentlich jetzt machen könnten
nicht machen aber wenn wir also an
restaurant kontrollieren dann ist da
eine kontrolle aber wie will ich denn
kontrollieren das also familie sich mit
familie b und familie c trifft obwohl
sie sich eigentlich nur mit familie
betreffen dürfte das haben wir nie
kontrollieren können ich verstehe ja das
ist natürlich ein pragmatisches argument
aber deswegen natürlich nicht weniger
wertvoll grundsätzlich hat würde ich was
kontakt beschränkungen und eingriffe in
freiheitsrechte angeht ist natürlich ihr
verhandlungspartner die fdp haben wir
mal rein war es partei vize wolfgang
kubicki gestern bei maybrit illner zu
sagen hatte dabei ging es auch um das
neue gesetz und vor allem auch um die
rolle des bundestags wir können
reinschreiben dass wenn eine solche
situation eintritt der deutsche
bundestag weitere maßnahmen lässt was
wir nicht wollen ist das noch einmal die
ministerpräsidenten ohne evidenz eine
entscheidung treffen am parlament vorbei
was sie momentan können wir wollen jetzt
dem parlament das recht so zurückgeben
darüber zu entscheiden welche massiven
grundrechtseingriff vorgenommen werden
müssen und welche hobbys nach unserer
auffassung das aus was wir machen sollte
sich daran etwas ändern wird der
deutsche bundestag definitiv hier sieht
man davon aus es ist kein parlamentarier
da der menschenleben aufs spiel setzen
will sollte es zu solchen situation
kommen die jetzt also drohen beschrieben
werden werden wir entsprechend reagieren
also da geht es jetzt nochmal um die
zuständigkeiten auch das ja ein
wichtiger punkt er spricht sich dafür
aus dass der bundestag gestärkt wird und
auch in gewisser weise gegen die
bisherige machtfülle der länderchefs
glauben sie denn dass sie als künftige
ampel regierung sollte es denn
erforderlich werden zusammen mit der fdp
dann auch wieder schärfer maßnahmen dann
beschließen werden können
jeden fall also wenn der druck da ist
dann wäre natürlich sehr hier wir können
es uns nicht leisten vorgeführt zu
werden und das schulden wir auch den
menschen dass es geht einfach gar nicht
alles und ich kenne ja auch ganz gut
also wenn also die not da ist und wir
wir müssen handeln dann würde sich dem
nicht verschließen und dafür würden wir
auch im übrigen sorgen dass wir würden
die mehrheiten organisieren können weil
ich habe da keinen zweifel daran dass
die andere der also verantwortung die
sie jetzt übernommen hat und übernimmt
auch gerecht wird gerade weil wir das
gesetz verhindern
ingrid knauer fragt uns über facebook
wieso reden wir nicht über die
hospitalisierung rate ist das nicht
wichtiger
hospitalisierung sraße ist wichtiger was
sie ist gestiegen
leider muss ich steigt weiter und sie
läuft nach also erst die aus
vitalisierung rate damals beschlossen
wurde also so wichtig so kam ich sage
ich habe schon gar also damals schon
davor gewarnt
dass die aus vitali xerox rate nicht die
bedeutung der inzidenz residenz ist
einfach viel wichtiger die jetzt wieder
ins plus die das alter der betroffenen
und ihr infektionsstatus kann ich
ausrechnen wie viele leute sterben
können also wenn ich es zusagen von
morgen die zahl der infizierten hätte
altersverteilung wie viele wagen gehen
dann kann sich ausrechnen ungefähr so
viel hatte ich genau sogar wie viele
menschen in drei wochen von jetzt das so
sterben und die gehen ja erst in vier
wochen sterben und ich schaute infiziert
haben die gehen ja in zwei wochen ihre
klinik und ich sterbe hier sind fünf
wochen das heißt wir haben also
diejenigen die sich jetzt infizieren wie
werden die werden jetzt in fünf wochen
stellen wir haben daher riesen also sein
da muss man so eine große zahl von
menschen jetzt schon also auf den
intensivstationen wo wir uns auch wissen
dass wir den die durch bekommen also
leider ist es so dass die theater
variante sehr schwer verloren und wenn
sie dann die beatmung beginnen oder gar
nicht wo beginnen dann sehen sie zum
teil schon also am anfang also dreimal
dieses tor genuss sehen sie den das
ausmaß des schadens und dann können sie
sich im prinzip schon also denken und
auf der zum schluss sterben gehört oder
überlebt und das läuft alles nach das
dauert ewig bis die menschen haben
entweder hospitalisiert oder gestorben
sind die residenz ist die einzige früh
warnstufe thorsten metzger fragt uns
über facebook herr lauterbach wie lange
und wie oft müssen wir uns impfen lassen
ähnlich fragen viele user die fragen
geht das jetzt ewig so weiter wird das
jetzt eine permanente impfung jedes jahr
oder wie ist das in etwa zu erwarten
das war es niemand genau und da kann man
da nur schätzen meine persönliche
sicht auf diese dinge ist ungefähr wie
folgt ich glaube nicht dass ist bei der
delta variante bleiben wird sondern ich
rechne damit dass auch noch also
ansteckende
varianten kommen und wir werden auch
noch varianten bekommen in der die gehen
die impfstoffe etwas besser zurecht
kommen somit glaube ich würde es nach
der dritten impfung nicht so sein dass
man sagen aber ich glaube dass zwei
dinger nicht sein werden hier wird es
wird nicht das in ein paar jahren so
sein dass man zurückblickt und sagt wir
haben uns dann drei mal impfen lassen
und dann war es vorbei das wird glaube
ich nicht dass es so sein wird und ich
glaube auch nicht dass es so sein wird
also wir haben zuerst also die
gefährliche abfahrt an die täter
variante gab dann war es aber zum
schluss vorbei das glaube ich auch nicht
das ist aus meiner sicht sind noch mehr
impfungen notwendig und das wird auch
noch gefährlichere varianten geben aber
es ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt unklar wo
das ganze endet ja gut das klingt jetzt
alles wenig hoffnung machen im prinzip
aber naja gut jetzt müssen wir erstmal
mit der situation umgehen so wie sie ist
aber ich würde sich doch noch mal bitten
gerade auf diesen punkt einzugehen weil
uns da wirklich auch sehr viele
zuschriften zu erreichen ich glaube das
ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt die leute
machen sich sorgen dass jetzt eben diese
epidemische notlage für beendet nicht
aber dass sie jetzt ausläuft und dass
eventuell die jetzt beschlossenen
maßnahmen nicht ausreichend sein könnten
viele verstehen dass einfachen ich
könnte vielleicht noch einmal deutlich
machen dass das ausreichend ist
ja es ist aus weil die länder haben die
instrumente zur hand die man braucht man
kann also die
die zahl der gäste also in öffentlichen
veranstaltungen oder beispielsweise
restaurants und cafés begrenzen man kann
zwei wieso ich für man könnte zwar
könnte sogar 1g durchführen man könnte
also
geben wir könnten das sehr sehr weit
gehen wir könnten also vorschreiben dass
diejenigen die also in
pflegeeinrichtungen ein und ausgeht dass
sie mit einem pcr-test getestet sind
also wir können wirklich da an der
schraube straße drehen das heißt die
instrumente sind schon relativ wie man
da einsetzen kann also es liest sich
denn damit lässt sich auch die kontakt
begrenzung also erzwingen wenn man so
will also wenn es jetzt zum beispiel nur
ein beispiel zu nennen wenn wir jetzt
zur pflicht machen sollen noch so in den
betrieben nur eine also zweig also plus
des o2 geht muss erlaubt wäre es jetzt
das könnten wir beschließen wenn die
fallzahlen danach geben was das würden
also wir können sie ja bald gehen also
den fall schnee ist die so glücklich das
hat mich besorgt
nicht erklären das war ja jetzt auch
nicht also um etwas zu rechtfertigen so
ich will einfach dass wir gemeinsam ihr
verstehen also wo wir stehen tatsächlich
die regeln die wir jetzt noch haben wenn
man die konsequent nutzt und das ist
derzeit das problem dass das nicht
passiert aber wenn man diese konsequent
nutzen dann kann man damit sehr weit
kommen
verstehen herr lauterbach was
versprechen sie sich von den kürzlich
zugelassenen medikamenten gegen chur
wird fragt uns becketts
ja dass
die beiden medikamente unterscheiden
sich ein bisschen in der wirkungsweise
und
die also das medikament von fall soll
quasi
das wird so stark wenn es sich bestätigt
wenn sich die ersten ergebnisse
bestätigen dass man da tatsächlich wenn
das medikament früh gegeben wird bei
jemandem der infiziert wird und der
risikofaktor laden könnte das
tatsächlich die sterblichkeit deutlich
reduzieren das könnte ich mir vorstellen
also in die in der studie nachgewiesen
dann also
90 prozent die sind bestätigt kannst du
das muss man erst mal durch eine größere
ich tu dir muss man das noch belegt
haben man muss auch schauen wie das
medikament aus dem routineeinsatz oder
solo aber das wirkprinzip
der also proteaseinhibitoren und auch
also die ergebnisse selbst sind
plausibel von daher glaube ich dass
gerade das also dass das medikament das
das als sehr wirksam sein wird das wird
aber noch dauern bis das kommt oder ja
das duell wird schnell zugelassen werden
die frage ist also wie viel produziert
werden kann also wird wie schnell wie
das dann bekommen aber es hilft uns
nicht durch diese vierte welle zu kommen
weil tatsächlich das muss gegeben werden
zu einem zeitpunkt und die viruslast im
körper noch stark steigt und diejenigen
die auch in die klinik zum beispiel
kommen und die wir dann beatmen müssen
und die jetzt die probleme haben da ist
die viruslast gar nicht mehr so sehr das
problem sondern da ist schlicht und
ergreifend das problem dass diese
menschen aus sodann eine abwehrreaktion
haben die also über schießen und nicht
mehr richtig funktioniert und auch zum
teil einen erheblichen gewinn schon
genommen haben ich hatte ja eben von
diesen ausbildungen also aufnahmen
gesprochen also wo man dann jemand
nachfragt zu beraten oder gar so
versorgt und man weiß aber dass diese
lohne sich nicht mehr erholen wird und
dass der patient nach einer geworden
dadurch sterben muss die fragen an sie
herr lauterbach bei unserer community
die sind schier endlos ich will jetzt
nicht über die gebühr damit
konfrontieren aber vielleicht hier noch
mit die deutschen sehen laut aktuellem
zdf-politbarometer corona wieder als das
größte problem an noch vor dem
klimawandel das war vor wenigen wochen
noch anders gleichzeitig schwindet aber
das vertrauen eigentlich in alle
parteien das problem zu lösen wohl auch
weil wir uns in einer phase des
regierungswechsels befinden was können
sie was kann die politik jetzt tun um
das vertrauen der bürger
zurückzugewinnen
also ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
wir die ruhe bewahren aber gleichzeitig
jetzt beherzt wer hier und was das
allerwichtigste ist keine partei also
nicht also die andere partei gegen die
andere etwas vorgeworfen das wahre wir
müssen nun also zusammenhalten und
konsequenz schnell reagieren daran muss
in die nächste woche wird dann ist er
wichtige woche seien in dieser hinsicht
müssen schnell reagieren und aus meiner
sicht müssen wir diese dinge machen die
ich eben beschrieben habe die mit neuen
gesetz möglich sind die müssen
konsequent umgesetzt werden dafür werde
ich auch selbst kämpfen ich verstehe
dass die bürger sehr unzufrieden sind
das kann bestens nachvollziehen und die
kritik ist auch berechtigt das muss man
sagen weil wir haben also ihr wir haben
hat der woche verloren es hat aber auch
damit zusammen gegangen dass es
tatsächlich auch ein paar
wissenschaftler gegeben hat also auch
funktionäre erste funktioniere die dann
also dann oder auch ein paar medien muss
enorm unter druck gesetzt habe freedom
day mach doch was die dänen machen also
sieht doch wieder irgendetwas schaffen
wagen sind werden bei uns all diese
begrenzungen weggenommen und so und da
hatte ich habe damals schon gespürt dass
person sind ein ganz kurzes glas bringt
ich war wir verlieren richtige zeit
jetzt ist es soweit wir das sehr
schlechte ins boot in europa und wir
haben geöffnet als wenn wir die besten
vorgarten das war nicht ganz wichtig die
einschätzungen des spd
gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
vielen dank dass sie sich heute abend
die zeit genommen haben wir wissen sie
sind viel beschäftigt im moment mit
corona sowieso aber auch
koalitionsverhandlungen also tausend
dank dass sie heute abend uns zur
verfügung standen alles gute schönen
abend an sie danke schön und
natürlich auch besten dank wieder bei
unserer community oder an unsere
community viel mehr danke für eure
zuschriften für eure fragen und
kommentare wie gesagt nicht alles dran
zu nehmen aber einiges konnten wir
unterbringen ein schönes wochenende euch
erstmal schönen abend und dann bis
demnächst schotter